this is a small victory for for
tolerance for not just me or not just
Sikhs for anyone that that comes into
the country that leaves the country
after the September 11th terrorist
attack it seemed like the only image
that you were seeing in the media of
turbans was on a terrorist you know on
on al Qaeda and so unfortunately the
minds of a lot of Americans a turban was
associated with terrorism
we have done informal surveys of our
community and we've seen the numbers as
high as roughly 10 to 20 percent of the
people surveyed have been subject to
some kind of hate crime whether it was
an attack or property vandalism
if we don't document it then we can't
prove that anything it exists so if we
don't know if it exists does not try to
solve